est ce qu'on a
figaro la ville est quasiment 13 heures
merci d'être avec nous en direct pour
suivre ce rassemblement des policiers à
paris qui se retrouvent donc près de
l'assemblée nationale à l'appel des
syndicats des milliers de policiers
venus de toute la france mais aussi le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
et des politiques de tous bords ainsi
que beaucoup de civils comme vous voyez
sur ces images en direct ont répondu
présent deux semaines pile après le
meurtre du brigadier éric masson à
avignon et à quelques semaines des
élections régionales
guillaume point vous êtes journaliste
fait divers au figaro bonjour bonjour
brune
bonjour à tous merci d'être avec nous
guillaume vous allez commenter avec moi
ces images en direct
première question qui qui permettrait de
planter le décor quelles sont les
raisons de la colère des policiers
pourquoi ils manifestent aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que la
colère des policiers elle vient elle
vient de loin
c'est un mouvement assez assez ancien
qui date d'il ya plusieurs années donc
déjà il ya eu des manifestations en 2016
au moment de l'agression deux des
policiers à viry châtillon et finalement
en fait ce qui a vraiment mis le feu au
le feu aux poudres bcc l'assassinât de
stéphanie me fermer à rambouillet dans
un premier temps et puis le meurtre
d'éric masson à avignon voilà c'est
vraiment deux événements qui ont voilà
qui ont un peu fait qu'ils ont un peu
fait déborder le vase quoi c'est
vraiment cessé ces deux événements qui
sont à souligner alors merci d'être avec
nous en direct nous allons donc suivre
cet événement nous sommes sur la page
facebook
parme sur la homepage du figaro ainsi
que sur notre page youtube n'hésitez pas
à nous dire dans les commentaires
toutes les questions que vous avez sur
le sujet n'hésitez pas à nous faire
partager votre ressenti sur cet
événement j'ai je relaierai vos
commentaires et vos questions à
guillaume ainsi qu'à notre équipe sur
place que nous allons rejoindre dans
quelques instants
je vous laisse donc un petit peu avec
ces images en direct on voit beaucoup
beaucoup de drapeaux de tous les
syndicats guillaume d'ailleurs quels
sont les
indiqua de police qui ont appelé à ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui alors là on
voit le gros ballon au centre qui est le
ballon du syndicat donc unité sgp police
fo sur la gauche donc c'est le syndicat
cfdt
un petit peu en dessous on voit le donc
le logo du syndicat synergie donc un
syndicat d'officiers et le scp donc
c'est le syndicat indépendant des
commissaires de police est sur la droite
allianz donc il ya plusieurs plusieurs
syndicats représentatifs
en tout il y en a sept ou huit
voilà en fonction des différents des
différents grades
je vous lis dans le chat dans le chatt
youtube de figaro vous êtes commencé à
être déjà nombreux dieulefit apolitique
bonjour à wendy sera également qui nous
donne son soutien inconditionnel fois
qu'il déclare son soutien inconditionnel
à toutes nos forces de l'ordre et à leur
chef monsieur darmanin bonjour également
à cri si luciano qui nous parle de
d'allemagne visiblement bonjour à tous
n'hésitez pas à nous dire également d'où
vous êtes d'où vous nous suivez d'où
vous nous regardez nous sommes en direct
donc sur la page youtube du figaro mais
aussi sur la homepage du figaro avec
guillaume points et notre équipe sur
place qui va nous faire mon ami cet
événement on n'écoute que mercy d'exiger
de nous protéger
au risque évidemment aujourd'hui de vos
vies merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après
[Musique]
perso j'ai écouté l'arrivée c'est génial
parce que ça rajoute un petit peu aller
bosser au on va vous envoyer quelques
clips vidéo donc d'admiration pour ces
gens là je suis pour la police merci
d'exister
donc c'est vrai que dans un contexte
parfois un peu de flics bashing
finalement c'est voilà c'est une voix
qui voilà qui est qui est intéressante à
entendre et à ma connaissance c'est le
seul entre guillemets people qui est qui
est présent qui est présent aujourd'hui
en tout cas alors dans le chatt beaucoup
de participants nous rejoignent bonjour
à um die la mort arrive qu'ils déclarent
est elle aussi son soutien qui affiche
son soutien aux policiers sambuc
également bonjour à vous et frites os3
bonjour à vous également
je vais faire un tour sur le chat du
figaro.fr aussi tout à l'heure n'hésitez
pas à poser toutes vos questions et à
réagir à cet événement qu'on va suivre
en direct nous allons vous laisser sur
ces images quelques instants et nous
reprendrons la main dès que nous aurons
notre équipe sur place sur le terrain
[Musique]
mais
nous
[Musique]
on
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et on a
le club
rien venir vous êtes avec ronan laisse
blaise est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
s'il ya beaucoup de monde malgré la
pluie et la wii est brune ya beaucoup de
monde les gens sont arrivés très tôt de
telle heure là on est à quelques
encablures de l'assemblée nationale au
pied de l'écran géant le soleil est au
rendez vous elle affirmé la pluie
pas vraiment sur la foule
faux lui nombreuses et danse
merci beaucoup
drap ou deux
peut-être que mon handicap police
semblait ni vraiment nombre aujourd'hui
on a aussi remarqué tout alem l'arrivée
de nombreux politiques
un peu plus bas que des parapluies
en tout cas l'ambiance semble plutôt
calme apaisé
mais beaucoup de monde
mais tout à l'heure j'ai alors commencé
à dire un petit mot je suis là à l'écran
gens se succèdent des images
on peut par exemple à il les remercia
nous on regarde bien on a vu du bien aux
clippers
le policier
dans différentes opérations l'opération
est un peu mettre en avant la politique
métro ce en avant leurs actions pour eux
pour cette manifestation soutien même si
montrer noté de nombreux et la présence
de nombreux civils
s'ils viennent vraiment pour dire leur
attachement à la valeur aux policiers
voilà donc une foule massive malgré la
pluie et aux nombreux politiques
présents
devant l'assemblée nationale
merci beaucoup marie amélie on vous
retrouvera tout à l'heure tout au long
de cet événement qu'on suit en direct
donc sur la page youtube du figaro mais
aussi sur l' empêche du figaro nous
sommes donc avec guillaume point
journaliste fait divers au figaro et qui
répond à toutes vos questions
il ya une personne dans le chatt
justement donc c'était pas vraiment une
question mais qui fait une remarque
adrien 54 merci de nous suivre
il déclare que le ministre de
l'intérieur manifeste avec la police tu
aujourd'hui et cela atteint un paroxysme
jamais vu dans l'histoire
est-ce que c'est historique justement
khamis de l'intérieur manifeste c'est
très très rare oui on a déjà vu des
politiques dans des marges plutôt dans
des hommages nationaux on se souvient
que françois hollande avait avaient
défilé avec plusieurs chefs d'état après
l'attentât de charlie hebdo mais c'est
vrai que de voir un ministre de
l'intérieur dans une manifestation de
policiers
en fait c'était c'était juste était
jamais arrivé quoi donc c'est vrai que
c'est assez assez c'est assez surprenant
et assez assez remarquable et si on
reste sur le chapitre politique le volet
politique
on s'attend à kehl à quelles forces
politiques en présence aujourd'hui
alors il ya beaucoup de politiques qui
ont dit qu'ils venaient que ce soit une
canine jadot d'europe écologie les verts
ça soit vallée valérie pécresse en fait
finalement le seul mouvement politique
qui a dit qu'il ne participerait pas
c'est la france insoumise en fait c'est
les sols c'est les seuls qui sont qui
sont absents de ce rassemblement
il y aura également peut-être le garde
des sceaux qui a dit que peut-être pas
serait une tête il ya aussi bout de
nombreux élus aient l'air également mais
il ya de nombreux élus et l'air et
olivier faur du ps
vraiment tout l'échiquier politique et
représentés sauf sauf la france
insoumise finalement il ya jordan
bardella aussi du rassemblement national
une sorte d'union qui d'union voilà qui
n'est pas nationale finalement puisqu'il
n'ya pas la france insoumis soit odile
odile wafflard bonjour sur le chat de
youtube nous dit merci merci aux
policiers et gendarmes qui nous protège
en caractères gras en majuscules donc ce
soutien est fort est ce qu'on peut le
comprendre
est ce que les français soutiennent les
policiers
il ya pas mal de sondages d'opinion qui
ont été faits sur ce sujet
en général les gens dire l'opinion
positive de la police en fonction des
sondages on est entre 65 et 80 % donc
c'est vrai que la police a une très
bonne image là il y avait un sondage qui
était paru en juin 2020 qui avaient été
publiées justement sur le site du figaro
on apprenait que 76% des français a une
bonne image de la police donc voilà 76%
c'est beaucoup après quand on rentre
dans le détail c'était 18% de très
bonnes opinions et 58% d'assez bonnes
opinions
mais bon on peut quand même dire qu'il
ya un soutien massif de la population
pour l'apport à la police quoi je vous
salue dans le chat du figaro.fr bonjour
à la torah bonjour à philippe bonjour à
chantal la goutte à olive du 80 bonjour
à tous merci de suivre avec nous ces
images on va regarder tout de suite les
clips vidéos projetées à l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la changer aujourd'hui je cite à compter
de la sanguine dans l'assemblée
nationale sur ces images on voit assez
dense et de nombreux drapeaux donc de
son étable de police cherchent à tunis
figaro.fr d'averses chantal la doute
par commentaire parce que pendant
longtemps ressenti
merci pour ce diaporama donc somme je
prédis publiquement mais aussi par la
pensée je vais faire un tour et gagner
le chat de notre page dutil 12 est de
plus en plus nombreux et nous savons de
claude therrien alexis m j -claude vous
revenez beaucoup notamment sur la
présence du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin
alexis elles nous demandent s'il ya des
actions particulières de prévu lors de
ce rassemblement
bio mais ce qu'on connaît un petit peu
de programmes d' avance alors le
programme en fait ça va être que les
différents secrétaires généraux des
différents syndicats en fait on prend la
parole donc là visiblement sûr sur les
sur les images ça va être le secrétaire
général du syndicat unité sgp police
donkey et grigori joron qui devrait qui
devrait prendre la parole en premier
d'ici quelques minutes et les
secrétaires généraux vont se vont se
succéder à la tribune finalement classé
grégory joron et d'unité sgp police fo
qui est le premier syndicat
représentatif si on prend tous les tous
les grades
visiblement son micro ne marche pas ces
problèmes techniques
on lui laissait aucune chance donc et
sans pitié
cette question sonne comme un défi une
menace qu'est ce que tu fais là lance
ecaussinnes comme si ça ne servait à
rien comme si nous policiers n'avions
plus rien à faire là éric masson faisait
simplement son travail il était là sur
un point qu'il en contrôle de police
banal qui lui a coûté la vie
notre collègue stéphanie était
simplement se font le travail doit
l'aider sortie pour une action banale
avant de se faire poignarder lâchement
et mourir notre collègue jean paul dans
la nuit de jeudi à vendredi dernier est
intervenu sur un tapage avant d'être
victime de jets de pierres autre
projectile atteint à la tête il est
encore hospitalisé aujourd'hui une
mission banal encore cette violence
quotidienne sous toutes ses formes de la
petite délinquance et la criminalité
organisée
en passant par les violences urbaines
jusqu'au terrorisme insultes frappe tu
tues les policiers de tout corps et de
tous grades sans distinction alors les
policiers s'interrogent également que
faisons nous la leur action
perpétuellement remise en cause leur
personne de remise en question il serait
raciste violent d'evian et un police
bashing et décomplexée qui efface les 3
millions d'interventions effectuées par
an il nourrit une haine anti-flic
palpable les policiers sont pourtant les
filles et les fils du peuple parfois
issus de l'immigration
souvent des classes moyennes et
populaires laborieuse et courageuse vos
policiers patauge et mettre la tête et
les demain là où beaucoup ne mettrais
même pas inquiet agressé en service est
désormais dans leur intimité lors noyau
familial insultés menacés
frappez égorgé divin comme des parias en
se cachant presque alors qu'ils exercent
le plus noble des métiers ces policiers
chers concitoyens avec peu de moyens
mais beaucoup d'envié de courage gare de
la paix ils garantissent vos libertés
votre tranquilité 24 heures sur 24 et
365 jours par an ils sont des
observateurs de l'état de notre société
il a côtoient dans ce qu'elle fait de
pire il on affronte ses mots et sa
misère plus que jamais face à cette
spirale de violence ce sont vos
sentinelle et aujourd'hui elle vous
alerte les policiers le coeur brisé
compose le 17
et on appelle à leurs concitoyens ils
doivent impérativement retrouver le
statut qui devait être qui devrait être
le leur pour exercer dignement fièrement
et efficacement
hors de question ici de faire le mauvais
procès de la justice exemple est en
sous-effectif nous faisons simplement le
constat du chemin emprunté par notre
société au travers de la justice depuis
une trentaine d'années
l'individualisation exacerbée de la
peine
l'empilage des mesures alternatives
engendrant l'érosion de celle ci jusqu à
les vider de son sens ce cas là l'idée
de pédagogie de toute notion de punition
voire de réparation
il est temps de changer de logiciel de
système de paradigme il est plus que
temps de rappeler le pacte républicain
qui nous unit au delà de toutes
sensibilités politiques celui de la
sécurité pour tous et partout
cette république qui donne à chacun la
chance de réussir et qui attend de
chacun le devoir de respecter son
prochain
c'est très technique qui donne à tous la
possibilité de vivre librement tout en
étant différents les uns des autres
cette même république aujourd'hui doit
répondre de manière forte claire et
assumée à tous ceux qui s'en prennent à
ses gardiens les tailles minimales
voilà les peines minimales sont les
agresseurs des forces de l'ordre le
message le message fort et clair que
nous attendons est-ce que ça réglera
tous n'ont sûrement pas mais il faut
bien commencer par quelque chose et je
l'assumé
symboliquement réuni devant l'assemblée
nationale la maison du peuple afin de
passer ce message dans le législateur
cette mesure n'est pas liberticide
elle n'est pas anticonstitutionnel
nauséabondes comme certains ont pu
s'égarer à le déclarer excusez moi je
cherche une personne qu elle est
nécessaire et urgente urgentes afin que
tous les flics ne se demande réellement
ce qu'ils font là est nécessaire avant
qu'il ne soit plus là mesdames et
messieurs
notre colère nos attentes notre soutien
doivent retentir jusque à rambouillet
avignon rive de gier
afin que les membres des forces de
l'ordre qui travaillent aujourd'hui nos
blessés nous disparus et leurs familles
sachent où qu'ils soient
aujourd'hui et maintenant qu'ils ne
seront jamais seul et que vive la police
française et républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci conserver merci vraiment
je pense à toi
et
la nappe lancé le secrétaire général
d'alliance fabien van hemelryck qui va
prendre la parole donc après grégory
joron d'unité sgp police
c'est le secrétaire général d'alliance
donc un syndicat qui est un syndicat qui
compte qu'il est représentatif au même
titre qu'une unité sgp fo
on écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
les premiers mots
[Applaudissements]
mes premiers mots et nos premières
pensées iront air éric masson stéphanie
mon fermés et tous nos collègues décédés
ou gravement blessés dans l'exercice de
leurs fonctions qu'ils soient actifs
administratifs techniques et
scientifiques
j'aimerais souligner la présence de nos
40 collègues d'avignon que je remercie
chaleureusement
eh bien non
j'ai bon
m
jim leur hommage leur soutien leur
mécontentement ils sont conscients de la
dangerosité de notre métier à
l'insécurité grandissante ou encore de
l'impunité omniprésente
qui aurait cru que nous policiers
serions obligés de réclamer que l'état
nous protège davantage
qui aurait cru qu'un jour les forces de
l'ordre
photo si mal protégé avec trente
policiers blessés par jour
mais parlons peu parlons vrai quelques
exemples pourquoi vite cher à notre
ministre
quinze véhicules incendiés des policiers
aspergé d'essence
un individu qui tentent de les enflammer
verdict de la justice
douze mois avec sursis pour l'auteur
c'est pas fini malheureusement les
familles brest policiers agressés à
coups de cocktails molotov un d'entre
eux manquent d'être brûlé gravement
verdict de la justice
l'auteur condamné venez vous bien un
stage de citoyenneté
[Musique]
digne-les-bains incendies de véhicules
tirs de mortiers sur les policiers jet
de pierre cinq interpellations
verdi encore une fois de la justice
l'ensemble des auteurs écoutez bien ou
relaxer pour les violences sur agents de
la force publique
on fait moins et ça sera le dernier
exemple parce qu'on pende en avoir des
dizaines que pour refus d'obtempérer
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui recel
de vol de véhicule
un policier encore gravement blessé avec
180 jours d'interruption temporaire de
travail et des séquelles graves soucis
monsieur verdict de la justice une
admonestation renoncer pour l'auteur
parce qu'il est mineur
[Musique]
le constat le constat il est édifiant
mais moi je vais vous dire mais pour
qu'ils nous font partie tout ça est
tellement insupportable
aujourd'hui il faut être clair alors
soyons clairs le problème de la police
et la justice
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ch'ti
et moi
elle rencontre des décisions est sûre
chez zac le citoyen le citoyen est en
droit de savoir
le citoyen est en droit de savoir
comment il punit les manèges et les
délinquants dans son pays
le citoyen est en droit de savoir
pourquoi toutes ces crapules mon pull
peur des forces de l'ordre
on peut s'attaquer aux policiers oui le
plan qui est encore plus d'agresser les
citoyens il ne faut pas s'étonner après
que moins d'un français sur deux a
confiance en sa justice
et que penser du message du garde des
sceaux
écoutez bien
à
avec ça s'il vous plaît le tout petit
peu dans tout ça on victimes et à
moindre des choses et personne n'en
parle malheureusement depuis des mois
par une journée et une nuit
nous sommes une patrouille ne soit la
cible de ces individus ou harris qui par
tous moyens sont prêtes à tout pour se
faire du bien
aujourd'hui nous sommes des dizaines de
milliers à côté de l'assemblée nationale
c'est un signal fort
un symbole important celui du jamais ça
plus jamais ça à part dont celui du
changement et maintenant il faut s'en
prendre
alors faites du bruit ce qui te plaît
n'ont pas d'autre choix que d'attendre
au bois et dont vous ne vous écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
mesdames et messieurs mesdames et
messieurs mesdames et messieurs les îles
aujourd'hui dans ce petit chien
électorale culture
mais une vis de conscience un devoir
dans les centres habilités changement
pour à la sécurité à la sérénité
et pour cela vous devez légiférer pour
mieux protéger mieux son rôle
aucun français pour représenter
l'ancienne complet
certains d'entre vous ou certains
d'entre vous à une époque
la bande a donc investi cette
opportunité j'espère j'espère
qu'aujourd'hui ce sera chose faite une
réponse pénale forte doit être mise en
place mais des peines minimales claires
doivent être instaurées avec célérité et
ses vérités il faut il faut briser la
spirale de l'ensauvagement et du chaos
avant que la situation ne soit plus
gérable par des moyens conventionnels ce
que personne ne souhaite
les magistrats rendent la justice au nom
du peuple français
il serait grand temps qu ils la rendent
au bénéfice du peuple français
ce sera pour nous le seul passage obligé
pour réaffirmer l'autorité de l'état
tant qu'il n'y aura pas de justice il
n'y aura pas de paix et surtout
n'oublions pas n'oublions pas je vous en
supplie les policiers sont payés pour
servir mais pas pour mourir
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
les terrines régi par une citation le
monde est en jeu réagir non pas de passe
à côté
[Musique]
oh merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du syndicat alliance qui a pris la
parole avec un discours assez offensif
sur sur la justice il a expliqué que le
principal problème de la police et la
justice la réponse pénale clairement des
accusations de laxisme de peine pas
assez sévères il a carrément dit le
problème de la police et la justice
ouais ouais ouais c'était là pour le
coup c'était vraiment c'était vraiment
clair son discours principal away la
réponse pénale est pas et pas assez
fermé et sofia d'ailleurs dans le chat
de la page youtube du figaro abonde dans
ce sens en disant le gouvernement et la
justice vous désarment donc la réponse
pénale effectivement été au coeur de
dessau discours hu est au coeur du
discours ouais il a donné des exemples
de policiers qui avaient été agressés
avec des peines de sursis qui avaient
été prononcées
on va écouter le troisième secrétaire
général on reviendra sur la place dalton
mais je voudrais dire aujourd'hui ce ne
sont pas des syndicalistes
ils se sont réunis samedi kalliste je
n'ai pas un métier
on est tous policiers aujourd'hui
chers collègues merci d'être venus si
nombreuses
nous avons appelé ce jour un
rassemblement citoyen et vous avez
répondu présent merci sincèrement du
constructeur merci pour nos policiers
morts en service
merci pour toutes celles et ceux qui
chaque jour sont désormais laisser
agresser violente et au quotidien
partout en france alors qu'ils
accomplissent la mission à laquelle vous
avez droit
celle d'assurer la sécurité de tous les
français nous pensons bien sûr à eric
stéphanie âgées entre 1 et 1 clarissa à
tous nos plans de lâchement assassiné ce
rassemblement c'est aussi pour dire stop
stop à la violence qui envenime la
france stop à ce qu'il a quatre qui la
personne ou qui par leur police ont
envie du coup leur absence aujourd'hui
prévu à semer le désordre et fracturer
la société
cette violence cette délinquance
envenime votre quotidien
l impact si la police nationale qui refa
ce malgré les difficultés malgré des
moyens qui font défaut malgré une chaîne
pénale déficiente et malgré une petite
minorité activistes qui attaquent la
république c'est à dire vous et nous
cela suffit cela a trop duré
nous sommes aujourd'hui un tournant un
délinquant ordinaire pour un motif
futile ou même inexistantes et capable
de frapper aveuglement et d'enlever la
vie à ceux qui vous protège eric a été
assassiné sur un simple contrôle du
quotidien
tous les policiers ne font régulièrement
stéphanie parce qu'elle travaillait dans
un commissariat de police
charles pasqua disait qu'il fallait
terroriser les terroristes
il est temps surtout de frapper les
petites frappes
il faut bien sûr les feras tu es
pénalement mais lourdement et fermement
[Musique]
parler de la réponse pénale s'est parlé
de la peine qui n'est efficace que si
elle est dissuasive appliquée est
effectué dans le plus court délai
aujourd'hui une minorité de la
population qui ne respectent rien
tous ces petits délinquants on côtoie
ses petites crapules ne respecte ni loi
ni leurs représentants ni même leurs
voisins et parents et ils sèment le
désordre et à vous la majorité qu'on dit
parfois silencieuse mais présente
aujourd'hui en très grand nombre que
nous adressons ce rassemblement car
c'est pour vous mais pour protéger nos
collègues de l'unsa police et l'unsa
face miss népal exigeront des
changements majeurs auprès du
gouvernement
la victime doit rejoindre au centre du
procès pénal et la trivialité de la
chaîne pénale chaque citoyen dans sa vie
est une victime potentielle
il ne faut jamais oublier cela il y en a
assez des réformes pour le droit d
auteur
le droit d'edel avant et le droit des
voyous mais je le garde des sceaux
réveillez vous
ouais
nous voulons une chaîne pénale qui
s'équilibre enfin que nos actions nos
interpellations ne pas trop notre
activité soit plus efficace notre
français c'est désormais le droit à une
sécurité qui tentent pour tous est
entourée que nous voulons la france doit
s'engager dans des réformes ambitieuses
et majeur pour consolider une police
républicaine
si c'est avec vous il faut protéger
celles et ceux qui vous protège et unir
lourdement ceux qui disent on empêche
oui il faut revoir à la hausse les
peines barak sont commises contre les
policiers et les gendarmes
oui il faut que les peines prononcées
soient enfin exécuté oui oui il faut
punir lourdement la récidive et agir
contre les multi réitérant même
lorsqu'ils sont mineurs oui il faut une
réforme ambitieuse de la procédure
pénale
toiles hautes et actes de procédure
désuet dans lesquelles se sont empilées
trop de réformes simplifier le travail
procédurale
les policiers pour apporter des réponses
pénales immédiate
il y en a assez des réformes successives
qui ne sont pas ça fait des années déjà
et mais on demande la même chose
aujourd'hui
ga les représentants du peuple qui sont
là nos élus c'est un e 2,3 dans
considération cela
[Musique]
il nous faut une loi de programmation
ambitieuse qui donne aux policiers une
meilleure formation une protection
matérielle morale juridique et social
pour lui permettre d'accomplir sa
mission
puis il faut des moyens pour la justice
également plus de magistrats de
greffiers d'éducateurs de centres
éducatifs et deux prisons pour que le
maillon essentiel de la chaîne pénale
que la justice puisse répondre à vos
attentes et à vos difficultés
oui il faudra de l'ambition politique
des décisions et des moyens
le premier ministre a ouvert le goût de
la sécurité le président de la
république s'est engagé à le clôturer
les attentes des policiers sont immenses
et les syndicats de la façon d'une sa
police scpn vidéo du ats le smps les
aisselles le spvm est ainsi que les
snippers exigeront la reconnaissance de
l'agent georgy teddy métier de policier
par une revalorisation de la prime de
risque la sécurité est et restera un
enjeu majeur et littoral alors qu'elle
devrait être une cause nationale
ce rassemblement doit être une prise de
conscience collective de tous nos
politiques aujourd'hui
j'ai fini mon propos en disant que ce
rassemblement n'est rien d'un mouvement
d'humeur ou d'un coup de gueule comme
certains peut le dire dans les médias où
certains politique désabusé
c'est en fait le début d'un long cycle
dans lequel nous serons exigeants et
intransigeant votre soutien nous donne
la conviction et la force de ne rien
lâcher
nous vous le devons merci à toutes et à
tous et vive la police nationale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors temps de jeu
le recteur général du syndicat unsa
police et nous allons tout de suite
retourné sur le terrain puisque marie
amélie bausch et je crois qu'elle a elle
est tombée sur un journaliste du figaro
christophe cornevin qui est rédacteur en
chef adjoint au figaro et spécialiste
des questions de sécurité marie-amélie
cet amour oui bruno l'argent si 5h09 un
journaliste rédacteur en chef jean
figaro est en charge des questions de
police et sécurité notamment
voilà donc que vous avez traversé de la
manifestation tout à l'heure dans quel
état d'esprit sont les policiers
devaient pu croiser les policiers sont
dans un esprit parce que je fais un
blanc qui sont ils sont meurtris
ils sont endeuillées par
l'assassinât de deux de leurs collègues
en juillet
cet anime ont fermé et
c'est xavier à
le brigadier le saviez pas son opinion
c'est des policiers qui apprend reçu un
nouveau coup de massue après l'agression
dont ont été victimes brigadier dans la
loire qui a été laissé dans le coma et
cd
en fait là ils sont dans une
manifestation qui va au delà des simples
revendications catégorielles
ils ne veulent pas simplement que plus
de moyens aux plus de reconnaissance
là ils veulent véritablement provoque un
débat de société et c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont convié à cette manifestation
aujourd'hui au pied de l'assemblée
nationale là où il ya la représentation
des députés ils veulent absolument
convoqué la conscience citoyenne parce
qu'en fait les agressions qui les mène
actuellement c'est des agressions qui
les visent
et qui vise aussi toute la société qui
est en ce moment dans un toboggan de
violences et on sait bien où ça va
s'arrêter
donc leur véritable envie tab
revendications allaient surtout le
peut-être pas vraiment sur la chaîne
pénale c'est à dire que jusqu'à
maintenant
il ya trop de policiers qui sont
agressés il ya trop de policiers qui
sont eux
véritablement laissé pour mort et alors
sauteurs finalement je suis une certaine
forme d'impunité qui aux yeux des forces
de l'ordre devient insupportable
finalement le ras-le-bol c'est une
manifestation de relever c'est du
ras-le-bol mais c'est aussi presque une
construction
ils veulent reconstruire quelque chose
ils veulent qu'on change de logiciel
en gros le il estime que la loi qui
régit le très doux pénale qui régit
actuellement les actions est là et qui
punit les délinquants a été forgée en
1810 ici il a été revu en 1994 et depuis
1994 soudain coup on a changé de
logiciel et on essayait d'être plus cool
on veut dire avec les manifestants
l'idée c'est de revenir beaucoup plus
ferme c'est notamment pour les
agresseurs de policiers et avoir des
peines minimales
pour enfin pouvoir punir ceux qui les
frappent ceux qui les brûle et ceux qui
tirent dessus pendant les soirées de
chaos qu'on connecte seulement ce dans
les cités et comment est perçu
aujourd'hui la prison des politiques et
notamment dirigé un manant famille de
l'intérieur premier chute de france on
vit ici on peut observer que tout à
l'heure j'étais
j'ai fait le tour de l'assemblée
nationale et j'ai accompagné une
trentaine d'élus
ceint de l'écharpé tricolore des députés
qui se dirigeait vers le ver le père de
la manifestation on peut observer quand
même que c'est que ces élus finalement
ils sont un peu seul les policiers ne
les prennent pas dans le rang c'est à
dire que ils témoignent de leur
solidarité et c'est très bien je veux
dire on voit damien abad de eric ciotti
les républicains qui sont très présents
ils sont dans leur rôle je crois un les
boutiques sens là aussi pour essayer
d'aider les les policières de peur
d'être à leur écoute
mais on voit que les policiers ne
veulent pas être récupérée politiquement
ils ont hier l'intersyndicale 1 par
exemple sont très unis à d'ailleurs
produit un tract qui est extrêmement
clair et qui disait qu elle ne voulait
pas donner ouvrir sa tribune
aux hommes politiques et aussi aux
membres du gouvernement si elle peut
être conçue comme une dédicace je dirais
moi gérald darmanin qui s'est invitée
aujourd'hui à la manifestation
il devait venir vers 13 heures
je sais pas s'il est venu mais parce que
il y à un monde fou ici hein
il n'y a plus de sueur milliers de
personnes donc mais en tout cas c'est
clair c'est que ils ne veulent pas de
régulation
d'accord mais donc la présence de gérald
ans maintenant on est le même en
labourant ciel présent c était comme
adversaire a priori on peut considérer
que la présence de gérald darmanin
n'était pas requise en tout cas parler
par les participants et ça c'est une
chose en revanche toute défense y vit on
peut y voir un paradoxe c'est d'ailleurs
parce que c'est vrai que journée dans un
mouvement qui est de nature à aller au
pied de l'assemblée nationale pour
contester ou faire pression sur le
gouvernement afin qu'ils le fassent
avancer les textiles et notamment quand
en cas d'agressions de policiers est qu
un des membres du gouvernement soient
dans la manifestation pompiers de
l'assemblée pour
pour participer à cette protestation
ça c'est un premier constat mais on se
recueillir derrière c'est que
darmanin
finalement nuit les seuils de jeu sa
partition dire que ils voient que le feu
à la maison
bien peu dans la maison police est donc
tout son intérêt c'est d'essayer de
calmer les trous de retrouver la paix
sociale et pour ce faire il se dit
bonjour et plongé dans le bain jamais
tes mains dans le cambouis et je vais
aller au milieu dans la fosse on avec
les policiers reste à savoir si la
mayonnaise va prendre et si c'est de
nature à calmer la colère des forces de
l'ordre merci christophe une dernière
question est ce que dans vos souvenirs
il ya déjà eu de telles manifestations
peut aussi important sinon pas semblant
30 syndicats l'intersyndicale et c'est
généralement les syndicats
et sans souvent en ordre dispersé c'est
à dire que
ça peut être les mesures des
revendications catégorielles il y a
différentes thématiques en fonction des
corps et carrières ou en fonction des
grades là ce qu'on peut observer c'est
que deux on a un front uni tous les
policiers sont soudés ils sont tous
ensemble et en fait là on peut on peut
remarquer qu' il faut remonter quasiment
octobre 2019
où il y avait eu 25 mille policiers dans
paris qui va faire une marche des
policiers en colère après une terrible
agression qui avait visé un des leurs
à l'époque c'était pour se plaindre des
suicides dans la police il y avait eu 7
en octobre 2019 on était au mode au
dixième mois de l'année il y avait juste
52 morts par suicide dans les rangs des
forces de l'ordre de la police
et par ailleurs il y avait des gros
problèmes matériels l'insignia moins de
suicides le bouvau le ministère de
l'intérieur fait beaucoup de choses pour
pour les policiers leur ont donné des
voitures ils ont investi assez
lourdement dans un programme immobilier
mais là on voit qu'on est au-delà de
sept de ces considérations catégorielles
les matériels on est sûr comme je le
disais tout à l'heure un débat de
société et la colère elle est très
profondément inscrite dans l'esprit de
les policiers et c'est très difficile de
les deux les de les ramener au calme
véritablement installée merci beaucoup
christophe rault labrune
bonjour un premier éclairage les dix
jours continuent à s'enchaîner
on reviendra vers mon printemps
juste à côté de l'assemblée nationale
avec ronan laisse buzz et vous venez
d'interviewer dont christophe cornevin
qui est également journaliste au figaro
spécialiste des questions de sécurité
si vous si vous nous rejoignez donc nous
suivrons en direct le rassemblement des
policiers où il ya visiblement beaucoup
de monde comme vous voyez sur ces images
en direct
malgré la pluie nous sommes donc sur la
homepage du figaro mais également sur
youtube et vous est d'ailleurs très
nombreux dans le chatt merci beaucoup
n'hésitez pas à poser toutes les
questions que vous avez vous affichez
vos messages de soutien à la police ou
pas d'ailleurs t'asseoir chaudhary qui
qui dès qu'ils déclarent bravo les
braves policiers nous sommes tous avec
vous je présente ma solidarité catherine
leconte
bonjour qui déclare les policiers
devraient se mettre en grève
huit jours pour que le peuple se rendent
compte à quoi ils servent
et encore christelle christelle san qui
déclarent tous derrière les policiers et
vive la france
guillaume point qu'un point vous êtes
donc journaliste fait divers au figaro
la plupart des discours des secrétaires
généraux des syndicats on mit l'accent
donc sur la réponse pénale d'une part
mais aussi ont démarré leur discours par
en énumérant on va dire leurs collègues
assassiné est ce qu'on peut faire un
point là dessus c'est sa basse et oui
ils ont dit le terme collègues lâchement
assassinés dont on se souvient il ya
certes un certain comment dire
assassinat qui sont assez emblématique
on souvient en janvier 2015 au moment
des attentats de charlie hebdo d'hyper
cacher qu'il y avait eu ahmed merabet
clarissa jean philippe qui avait été
assassiné un autre assassinat qui avait
beaucoup marqué l'opinion publique aussi
c'était celui de jean-baptiste salvin et
jessica se déverse était magnanville qui
avaient été assassinés donc par un
islamiste sous les yeux leur petit
garçon il y avait eu xavier juge les
aussi que c'est en avril 2010 est sûre
les sur les champs elysées là aussi par
un terroriste islamiste avait eu le
fameux attentat la fameuse attaque de la
préfecture de police en octobre 2019 qui
avait fait 4 morts et puis dernièrement
c'était fanny m'enfermait rambouillet
qui a été égorgé dans le dans le sas de
de son commissariat donc voilà beaucoup
de beaucoup finalement deux visages
qu'on a un peu oublié mais qui ont voilà
qui ont marqué l'opinion publique j'ai
une autre question dans le chat tout à
l'heure que j'ai relevé
alexis m qui était dans le cas de
youtube qui nous demandent savez vous si
les représentants politiques tels que
jordan bardella qui qui ont déclaré qu
il ya des claques y seraient présents
pourraient prendre la parole lors de ce
rassemblement alors c'est pas c'est pas
prévu a priori dans le protocole c'est
uniquement les uniquement les
secrétaires généraux des syndicats de
police qui vont qui vont prendre la
parole donc normalement c'est pas assez
pas prévu c'est paraissait pas au
programme xavier harel également dans le
chat je lis votre commentaire bonjour je
suis français et fier de l'être je vous
écris depuis la floride et vous assure
que nos compatriotes vivant à l'étranger
sont outrés du cynisme du ministre de
l'intérieur
beaucoup beaucoup de commentaires
effectivement sur gérald darmanin ainsi
que sur eric dupond moretti dans les
jets de chat un à la fois celui du
figaro et celui de youtube et il ya
également énormément de commentaires sur
la réponse pénale et sur la justice
est-ce qu'on peut revenir un petit peu
là dessus
guillaume quels sont les gages qui ont
été apportées aux policiers après le
meurtre d'éric masson
alors ça c'était vraiment très important
dans l'est dans tous les discours qu'on
a entendu c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui ressortait c'est la réponse pénale
en fait la principale revendication des
policiers aujourd'hui donc après toutes
ces agressions etc
c'est qu'il ya une peine minimale pour
les agresseurs de policiers or pour le
moment le gouvernement a annoncé la
création d'un observatoire de la réponse
pénale
donc il va être mis en place en juillet
2021 et donc en fait cet observatoire va
permettre qu elle va permettre en fait
de suivre toutes les toutes les peines
prononcées après des infractions contre
des policiers
donc concrètement voilà un policier se
fait tabasser dans une cité grâce à cet
observatoire on pourra avoir un
li de la peine pour le moment il n'y a
pas de peine minimale pour les
agresseurs de policiers à l'ordre du
jour la seule chose c'est que jean
castex donc en mai 2021 donc il ya
quelques jours annoncé que la peine de
sûreté pour les agresseurs de policiers
condamnés à la perpétuité la peine de
sûreté elle est passée à 30 ans donc un
agresseurs de policiers qui tue un
policier par exemple la peine de sûreté
passe à 30 ans met donc les syndicats de
police veulent aller plus loin en
instaurant une peine minimale en fait
merci guillaume on va retourner tout de
suite en direct pour voir la foule
donc la foule massée à côté de
l'assemblée nationale à paris on vous
laisse sur ces images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est nécessaire soit mais pas que trois
parties peut pas se jouer
tollé à cette heure là semblait c'est
bientôt fini reste encore un témoignage
après il y aura une vie de silence et
marseillaise qui va rentrer dans
l'histoire
je manque d'écouté cet extrait amati que
ce qui s'est passé a pas longtemps on
lance la vidéo merci et on écoute
produit vous témoigner anonymement
pourquoi ce sera ma première question il
va qu'on me reconnaisse pour protéger ma
famille première et unique raison pour
protéger ma famille ça veut dire aussi
aujourd'hui ou témoigner à visage
découvert nous risques dans les quelque
chose pour une famille pour passer pour
les prévenir que guérir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé il ya quelques
mois c'est octobre 2020 même s'il est
devenu à 23 heures j'ai reçu un appel
pour me prévenir que le mari a été
blessé par balle avec son collègue
toutes les chansons d'amy qui vous
arrive dessus parce que
on comprend des gros on les entend on
les réalise pas pas tout de suite en
tout cas je me suis remis aux plus gros
marché n'est pas conventionné à
l'hôpital et puis j'ai réalisé qu'en vue
quand le sang était méconnaissable au
niveau du visage
l'ancien romain guillou et on comprend
et l'horreur qu'ont agi les voir travers
ces lignes et on s'est pas est ce que ça
va donner
donc on n'est pas d'issue à ce moment
qu'on n'est pas l'issue je me souviens
du médecin du samu qui agit pour me
parler ils sont simplement après c'est
fou je me souviens qu'il s'est accroupi
devant moi qu'il était très
bienveillants pour me rassurer puisqu'il
départ le ratio points quand tout est au
ralenti on voit les choses ont donc ces
enchères de la sidération j'ai 7 ans et
qui est prêt c'est parti pour plusieurs
zéros d'incompréhension prenez le temps
mes buts et d'essai s'implique donc là
clairement c'était la fin je repense à
quotidiennement ou presque on l'aura
annoncé tout de suite qu'on était
policier on leur a montré en quarts
professionnelle et la sas un menu simple
on comprenne bien pourquoi et derrière
je suis rapidement
à terre on étrangle je prends des coups
de pied dans la tête sur le sol est la
bienvenue sa part m aux normes qui était
accrochée à la ceinture
zen et hui sécurisé il a réussi à sa
lampe arrêt j'ai crié non parce que
j'imaginais pas qu'ils puissent à navire
à me tirer le fumier ensuite à tirer sur
mon collègue jetterez la première j'ai
hurlé gérer la deuxième j'ai perdu
connaissance j'ai entendu les
détonations
après je ne doute ex thé sur mon
collègue en tirer
et après quand je reprends connaissance
de plus personne j'ai le visage
complètement tuméfié jouant que des
neiges onze mois les jambes de mon
collègue jean temps de céréales pour moi
ce produit c'est vraiment c'est vital
que je fasse rapidement quelque chose
nous voulons c'est pour moi ce sont les
risques du métier
maintenant on peut et qu'on doit être
confronté à la violence et pas de façon
de gratuite pour moi on a franchi un cap
c'est à dire que maintenant nous sommes
des cibles
quand les gens s'attaquent à un policier
qui s'attaquent aussi avant tout un
homme et une femme et ils ont des vies
ils ont des enfants ils ont des familles
eric stéphanie xavier jean baptiste
jessica la liste est tellement longue
que en fait c'est ça ni dramatique et on
se demande quand est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter ça s'arrête en fait on est
sincèrement que ça s'arrête jamais et
c'est dur c'est dur denver est
évidemment moins je veux j'ai mon métier
je suis rentré dans la police par
vocation
maintenant on n'a jamais je vois les
choses différemment des craintes mais on
n'en parle pas assez
c'est pas bon
on évite le sujet parce que parce que
voilà pour l'instant la reprise n'est
pas envisageable pour chaque chose en
son temps pour se reconstruire
à ce moment là vous pensez de votre mari
peut mourir on l'a dit tout de suite que
ses jours n'étaient pas en danger
on l'a dit tout de suite on état dans
lequel j'ai découvert au mari il était
conscient et une parmi d'autres hostiles
vital n'était pas engagé je vous le
savez oui justement et de rassurer comme
je pouvais prendre sur moi pour me dire
de ne pas en rajouter c'est de faire ce
que je pouvais pour le porter vous
pourrez dire que je suis là c'est
quelque chose qui les chamboulements
devine d'un seul coup on n'est pas
préparé on le sait on le pense qu'on se
protège donc on disait ça va pas arriver
quand la personne pour téléphone a sonné
que la personne n'a prévu je vais le
prénom de la personne qui m'a prévenu
j'ai su immédiatement je suis
immédiatement vu leur que jean prouvé
tout autre
mais j'ai su que c'était pas normal en
tout cas de recevoir cet appel n'a pas
recette personnelle à ce moment là
aujourd'hui ce que voulez vous dire
c'est que c'est de pire en pire
quel est le quotidien des fonctionnaires
de police en france et qu'est ce qui se
passe d'après vous il commande d'arriver
là
environ
il faut que les policiers de france est
flic de france tous grades confondus ton
service qu'on plonge fasse attention
parce que la réalité du terrain du
travail de flics tout ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement la
triste réalité et l'uniforme que porte
le flic ou le brassard que porte le flic
est maintenant synonyme de m'abattre
alors c'était dur mais c'est le
sentiment qu'on peut peut-être avoir
même si bonne partie de la population
est fier de sa police sage et personne
n'en doute
depuis septembre plusieurs flics sont
tombés donc ça fait que cette ombre
c'est de pire en pire
les recherches explique le père de
famille pendant lequel g se passe si si
si
toute une famille qui change c'est toute
une carrière professionnelle qui
chamboule c'est tout un avenir qui
chantent mais est ce qu'on peut dire que
votre mari quand il a décliné son
identité de policiers s'est décrit
reconduit je comprends n'en serait pas
là dessus je n'étais pas sur place car
ils ont décliné leur identité et la
préméditation noir violence les balles
dirai comment vous expliquer qu'on en
arrive là aujourd'hui c'est de l anti
flics en france est-ce qu'on peut
l'expliquer déjà est-ce que ça
s'explique s'explique pas en fait on
entend une convention qui menace des
noirs d'afrique sont frappées de fiction
tuer des fictions pressé c'est pas
normal vous soyez milliers de justice
aujourd'hui vous demander en quoi est ce
qu'il ya une solution
aujourd'hui pour stopper cette haine
anti-flic
pas moins de la force et la solution
française individus sont punis ça c'est
une chose
on peut toujours demander plus c'est un
propos aujourd'hui votre mari est encore
à l'hôpital en tout cas hospitalisés
était encore blessé est dans sa tête et
dans sa chair l'hiver au 30 du service
dans l'immédiat quand m non la
réplication est trop longue pas dans
l'immédiat est en tout cas plus en
service opérations qu'est ce qui a
changé aujourd'hui par rapport à tours
pour physiquement il a pu lui-même qui
n'aura plus et ben capacité qu'avant on
pourra toujours des douleurs des
séquelles physiques ne pourra plus jouer
au foot avec les enfants pourra plus
courir alors
les deux bouts vont avancer
on sera à vivre différemment
différemment on dit souvent que le drame
n'arrive pas par hasard
aujourd'hui vous révolter en colère et
curé je suis en colère
la priorité c'est de se concentrer sur
l'état de santé mon mari s'est rétabli
ce que d'autres femmes valent bien
toute l'énergie est utilisée pour moi
qui on essaye de ne pas se laisser
déborder par des sentiments qui vous
ferez de venir et gris parce que c'est
pas le but d'y accoler habitants la
colère aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'ils ont
envie de dire aux dizaines de milliers
de policiers qui vont gouverner
j'ai envie de leur dire que de faire
attention et de prendre une fraction de
secondes parfois pour avant de partir
que ce soit la cour est qu'aux mondiaux
pour un flag même pour une simple
vérification des produits une demi
seconde pour se poser pour réfléchir de
toujours penser c'est pour lui glisser
contente à côté qui décide
parce que parce que ça va être aussi une
façon de les protéger quand ils gèrent
leurs enfants protéger leurs enfants
leurs familles ce qui est arrivé à mon
bas risque d'un philippe c'est avec ce
qui t'arrive en outre c'est la vraie vie
ce n'est pas juste des faits divers on
voit un intérêt ou regardent en deux
heures après on passe à autre chose
parce que même si c'est terrible on se
protège en pensant aussi aux anges c'est
pas moi qui suis touché c'est la vraie
vie honnêtement qu'il faut que les
fuites prennent conscience qu'il faut
faire attention et que le plus important
reste vraiment la famille
ces conditions sa vie d une femme de
policiers municipaux miage touchant
cette fois assez en colère
est-ce que c'est fréquent que les
familles des policiers soient visés
soient attaqués bah c'est de plus en
plus fréquent en fait et ça fait partie
des revendications aussi d'aider des
policiers en fait ils ont l'impression
pas seulement eux mais aussi leur
famille d'être de plus en plus ciblées
de plus en plus scrutée visez donc que
ce soit via des menaces de mort ou alors
récemment peut donner un exemple c'était
à epinay sur seine en avril 2021 des
dealers avaient affiché des photos des
familles des policiers dans un hall donc
là on se dit que ça va quand même très
très loin quoi de voilà c'était il y
avait des photos des enfants des photos
de mariage
donc cette préoccupation pour la pour la
famille de plus en plus prégnante pour
les ponts pour les policiers quoi vous
qu'il nous rejoigne et si vous venez
d'arriver donc on nous suivons en direct
le rassemblement des policiers à paris
juste à côté de l'assemblée nationale
vous êtes nombreux dans le chatt
d'ailleurs bonjour à sadok bonjour un
robert bonjour à cha cha cha a ghost 93
à mario tour et raphaël grolier à dexter
jo 93 vous qui nous regardent et donc
sur la page youtube du figaro
il y à un commentaire que j'ai relevé
tout à l'heure donc le pseudonyme je
pourrais pas le prononcer cgh fjh h
bref qui relevait une question que j'ai
à vous soumettre du coup guillaume est
ce que les policiers peuvent faire grève
il déclare donc grève totale de la
police les anti flics vous suppléeront
de revenir est ce que c'est possible
pour apprécier de faire grève alors il
ya une petite nuance ils n'ont pas le
droit de faire grève mais ils ont le
droit de participer à des manifestations
donc une manifestation comme aujourd'hui
qui est sporadique qui dure voilà qui va
durer deux heures donc là il n'y a pas
de problème par contre ses regrets sur
plusieurs jours ils ont pas le droit
voilà c'est conformément au code de la
sécurité intérieure il ya un autre petit
point c'est que selon leur code de
déontologie sont tenus au devoir de
réserve
donc voilà c'est pas le droit de grève
mais le droit de manifester on va
regarder tout de suite ces images en
direct
est ce que vous savez qui c'est
guillaume qui parle on va écouter tout
de suite est-ce que cela vous que c'est
peut-être que certains que le oui le
rappeur chaotique 747 mais on va écouter
tout de suite et on vous précise sa des
cons à l'information
policiers et pas d'éducation
c'est normal à dater les radios comme
skyrock n'apprendront jamais le
patriotisme et l'amour de la nation
d'attention aux sports
[Applaudissements]
la france a son histoire c'est mon rôle
à jouer faire réfléchir et mon devoir
même banni par la gloire ouais je
m'appelle karim
j'aime la france et son décor mes prises
de position ont valu de jolis menaces de
mort j'apporte une importance
particulière aux métaphores
il promeut dire ce que je pense je me
tape de leur disque d'or mon pays est
malade jetant la température restant
loin des caricatures jeu soigner ses
plaies s'est fracturé rappeur algérien
est fier d'être français
à cause de mes pensées et quand ils
sachent qu'ils sont prêts à me défoncer
ni à la dass marianne m'a appris le
respect la tolérance de vivre ensemble
hamon elle m'a donné la paix gosses de
la rue c'est le sida quand porter ma
mère vos petits rappeurs de merde pour
les caïds endormi par de l'herbe
il donne après ça tu en dis moi tu
t'attendais à quoi
ils ont mangé fargo nos gosses en
racontant n'importe quoi
je me sers de mon micro comme un porte
voix c'est avec mon pied du mur fut ma
confiance et porte- mois d sinon un
nouveau monde
bâtissons à chaque seconde servons nous
dépasse et continue le seul espoir
succombe s2 mentaliser dp divers pour
diviser
ça pousse à la révolte ça chante la
haine sur un air de gratte
j'ai le regard vide le coeur ensanglanté
je reste propre à sa leur haine à
l'image de ce policier plaques
j'ai pas envie de perdre de rentrer dans
le propos je pèse chacun des mots en
défendant mes propos sur le même radeau
sur le même bateau unis pierre sous le
même drapeau
j'ai pas envie de perdre y rentrer dans
le propos je pèse mes mots en défendant
les propos sur un même radeau sur un
même bateau unis fief sous un même
drapeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces 4 745 de son vrai nom karine
bouchard lourd et c'est un rappeur
niçois de 38 ans qui est je vais [ __ ]
là blouin connue pour être pro forcément
font du rab ouvertement
c'est ce rappeur c'est rentrer dans des
clichés et bande de la merde à nos
gamins à leur faire croire que la ville
il a sorti un éphèbe dénudé j'entends
qu'il ya droit de flics génération
lorsque ces producteurs avec la
responsabilité que ces médias prennent
leur responsabilité aujourd'hui on a
tout un pays à reconstruire il faut pas
attendre des prochaines présidentielles
pour le construire
il faut reconstruire maintenant dans
l'amour et l'unité collet souhaite vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors les services de police je te
donner la formation vous êtes plus de
35000 bras
[Applaudissements]
alors que deux ans
merci madame glissa conjoncturelle
charles haas est à la [ __ ] toujours
sous typologie poteau soutien total à
toute la politique déclare continuer
votre copain qui sont en jeu est la
gestion doit rendre des comptes aux
français et communautaire tout à l'heure
mario touré qui chat beaucoup d'ailleurs
sur notre chaîne youtube mariotto est
qui qui déclarait je soutenais les
policiers mais ça c'était avant les
gilet jaune
on n'a pas oublié non plus guillaume
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire sur ce
mouvement le gilet jaune depuis toujours
il y avait un il y avait un rapport
d'amnesty international qui avait été
publié donc après le après le conflit
des gilets jaunes qui avaient fait état
donc de 1800 blessés du côté des forces
de l'ordre et de 2500 blessés
côté manifestants on se souvient
notamment de voilà d'image c'est assez
violente je viens de dire de
manifestants qui avaient pris des des
tirs de l bd parfois parfois dans le
visage etc
donc voila c'était le le bilan 1800
blessés côté policier 2500 côté côté
manifestants je continue de vous lire
n'hésitez pas à poser toutes vos
questions ou à donner vos messages de
soutien ou à l inverse si vous ne
soutenez pas les policiers dites le nous
et et donnez-nous les oraisons un petit
mot ou encore des syndicats je crois
bien qu'il reprenne la parole on va les
écouter
maintenant penser à tous vos collègues
qui ont été blessé ou tué
je m'offre une minute de silence
merci
on peut applaudir nous ne pouvons pas
nous séparer sans ce chant ty
révolutionnaire qui nous unit tout ici
pour ce moment privilégié je vais vous
demander d'accueillir une jeune soprano
il des plus grandes sopranos française
qui est venu pouvoir et qui va chanter
vous l'avez entendu tout à l'heure la
marseillaise évidemment vous pourrez
chanter avec elle je vous demande
accueillir une salle de président pour
mademoiselle clos et hop voilà lyrique
il ya toute sa place
j'ai un micro qui marche bien je suis la
porte bien est ce que ça marche pour toi
la preuve le micro vas-y
je donne le mien alors non la risi me
dit quoi le lytro marche dans les
vergers
c'est pas évident a cappella que les
cerveaux la plausible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'ai fait un bras
[Musique]
à
hu
m
aso
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si c'est vrai qu'à cliquer le silence à
ce rassemblement parisien des policiers
puis la marseillaise chantée par une
chanteuse lyrique en direct on va
retourner tout de suite sur place avec
retrouver notre équipe donc mariés
amélie pochet et renan l'aise blaise qui
je crois sont encore aux côtés de
christophe cornevin marianelli cette
année le choix
alors donc j'ai aujourd'hui je suis
simplement les électeurs étaient
renseignement
des sorties se sont succédé mais
l'erreur
si vous a marqué dans ses discours ce
qui m'a ce qui m'a marqué c'est plus que
la forme c'est peut-être déjà le le fond
c'est à dire que effectivement on
partait sur quelque chose qui était
véritablement un débat de société
c'est ce qui était affiché au départ et
on se rend compte que les policiers
restent quand même très en colère et
ulcérée par leurs propres turpitudes ce
qu'ils sont en train de vivre
actuellement ils ont cité des exemples
très parlant notamment à tour à tour
quoi une ville qui est cher au ministre
de l'intérieur ou ou très récemment il
ya quinzaine de véhicules qui ont été
incendiés des policiers quand et aspergé
d'essence et enflammé et au finalement
le l'auteur de cette agression
manifestement aurait eu douze mois
simplement avec sursis alors évidemment
quand ces exemples ont été donnés là
devant les devant la foule ici présentes
ça a été accueilli à clamer passe est
accueilli par des sifflements et des
cris de colère c'est dire qu'on est
quand même face à face à une profession
quand même qui est à vif à cran il ya
plein d'exemples comme ça qu'ils ont été
données ce que je remarque aussi c'est
que les policiers restent encore très
très remonté contre le police bashing
ils n'ont quand même pas oublier le le
mot d'ordre
le rassemblement s'est retrouvé sur la
chaîne pénale et avec des mots très
forts notamment il ya fabien
vanhemelryck qui est un des grands porte
parole de secrétaire général d'alliance
ya des principaux représentants des des
gardiens et gradés qui dit soyons clairs
c'est le problème de la police et la
justice c'est elle qui doit rendre des
comptes et le citoyen doit savoir
qu'elles sont comment là comment la
justice travaille et qu'est ce qu'on
doit faire pour essayer de l'améliorer
et la belle et il est acclamé c'est à
dire que la police est quand même un
petit mot convaincu que la justice et
est défaillante 1
même si on essaye de ménager un peu cet
outil judiciaire il est quand même
pointé du doigt et d'ailleurs le garde
des sceaux lui même
a été mise en cause à plusieurs reprises
pendant les discours
en fait les policiers sont vraiment
encore en plein désarroi et il ya une
phrase qui pourrait résumer un peu cette
séquence et qu' ils disent généralement
ce sont les français qui a peu qui font
le 17 pour nous aider et là c'est la
police qui fait le 17 pour demander à la
représentation citoyenne de venir à nos
côtés écoutez no no no no no
sollicitations demandé nombreux écouter
nos requêtes et venir nous nous épauler
dans un dans un combat qu'il ne peut pas
mener tout seul contre la délinquance
parce que c'est vraiment la faire de
tous et je crois que là le fait qu'il ya
plus de 30000 personnes prouve qu'ils
avaient une communion autour de 7 2 7 de
ce mouvement donc justement idv
on a annoncé tout à l'heure un chiffre
35 mille participants environ
qu'est ce que ça dit finalement ce chip
gm inédit si je ne m'abuse
c'est un chiffre absolument énorme il
faut remonter à dao tape 2019
pour pour avoir une telle participation
est encore en octobre 2019 qui atteint
un record déjà il y avait eu 27 mille
personnes qui battaient le pavé
là on a plus de 30000 ce qui veut dire
que en fait on est un niveau de
d'insatisfaction de colère et de et 2
et peut-être pour l'instant de des
directions dans l'oeuvre la profession
jamais atteint donc il va falloir
absolument que le ministre de
l'intérieur notamment qui est en train
de lâcher dès les nouveaux de la
sécurité trouve je dirais la botte
martingale coincé des morses désamorcer
la grenade dégoupillée qui n'a
actuellement dans la poche
très bien merci beaucoup christophe ici
la manifestation comment faire
je suis
une manifestation donc extrêmement
suivie dans laquelle les discours saison
enchaîner rapidement avec des
revendications
garde du corps c'est à tes émotionnel
fort
voilà comment est ce que je peux vous
dire qu'on l'instant le moment breen
mais là les gens commençaient à bouger
sur scène donc les 3000 personnes qui
étaient présents siège ici
souvenirs la police et
il ya peu
m
merci mariam et l'ébauché et merci à
redan laisse baisse qui filme mais filmé
ces images encore beaucoup de monde dans
le chatt notamment sur sur youtube
bonjour à nicole fort à cette eau qui
déclame son soutien total aux policiers
leurs revendications sont légitimes les
moyens dont ils sont dotés sont à
l'évidence totalement insuffisant pour
leur protection physique et psychique et
sophie boutaud également dont je vois
apparaître le nom pour la première fois
dans le chat qui elle aussi déclame son
soutien aux forces de l'ordre
il ya une question tout à l'heure que
j'ai que j'ai relevé que j'ai noté pour
vous guillaume point peut-être le
pseudonyme s'était trouvé le nom qui
déclarait que un policier national
touche 1500 euros et ce montant augmente
toute sa carrière est ce qu on a des
informations peut pratiquer sur sur le
salaire déplore les conditions
matérielles des policiers le salaire
c'est en ça voilà c'est aussi un sujet
n'était pas central aujourd'hui dans
leurs revendications mais c'est un
problème par exemple un adjoint de
sécurité qui débute en ile de france je
suis allé voir c'est autour de 1300
euros
un gardien de la paix qui débute ses
1700 euros
et d'ailleurs les adjoints de sécurité
enfin beaucoup explique que parfois ils
doivent dormir dans leur voiture
donc c'est quand même assez incroyable
quoi un adjoint de sécurité qui débarque
en ile-de-france avec 1300 euros c'est
vrai qu'on peut on peut pas faire grand
chose
et d'ailleurs dans un livre c'est linda
kebab qui est qui et au syndicat unité
sgp elle explique quand elles arrivent
en ile de france elle a dormi dans sa
voiture pendant six mois donc voilà que
tu es passé logis avec le salaire bas
parce que voilà ouais c'est ça avec 1300
euros c'est compliqué donc apparaître en
colocation
ou être dans un logement social c'est
très difficile voilà s'il ya aussi ce
sujet là et est ce qu'on sait si c'est
une profession qui attire les jeunes
alors ça c'est difficile à savoir jeu
franc franchement je sors je saurais je
ne saurais pas vous dire je ne saurais
pas vous dire si c'est une profession
qui attire toujours
en tout cas la notion de dangerosité
les agressions à répétition on peut
imaginer que ça que ça en décourage plus
d'un notamment parfois des jeunes qui
arrivent de province et qui sont qui
sont va dire propulsé dans des noms des
quartiers un peu difficile voilà c'est
passé pas évident il faut quand même
avoir une résistance psychologique et
qui est assez importante après sur le
nombre de jeunes qui présente le
concours là je ne saurais pas vous dire
ce rassemblement donc en manifester la
colère donc des policiers je voulais
savoir avec vous guillaume est ce que
c'est les violences envers les policiers
sont sont vraiment en os ou parce que
vous avez récolté des statistiques sur
ce thème alors il ya un article
justement du site du figaro sur ce sujet
qui était paru alors les policiers
blessés le nombre a été multiplié par
deux en quinze ans c'était un rapport de
la police nationale donc il y avait trop
il ya eu trois mille huit cents
policiers blessés en 2004 il y en a eu
sept mille quatre cent en 2010 neuf donc
ça a quasiment doublé est bon c'est vrai
que quand on suit l'actualité au
quotidien
voilà de près il n'ya pas un jour où il
n'y a pas des policiers attaqués ou
caillassés et tirs de mortiers c'est
vraiment vraiment quelque chose de voilà
malheureusement qui est devenu presque
presque banal et quotidien
sans parler les cas les plus graves on
l'a vu dernièrement des assassinats des
meurtres
on peut peut-être d'ailleurs revenir sur
surtout ces policiers assassinés ces
dernières années vous l'aviez évoqué
tout à l'heure mais si vous nous
rejoignez guillon voulait peut-être
ouais ouais bah il ya des visages qui
sont qui sont qui sont malheureusement
connu du grand public maintenant il y
avait
donc un maître merabet clarissa
jean-philippe donc ça c'est en janvier
2015 et au moment des attentats de
charlie il y avait eu le couple donc
jean baptiste alvin et jessica hausner
qui avait été assassiné à magnanville en
2016 donc sous les yeux de leurs petits
garçons il y avait des avis et juge les
non classés en avril 2010 est sur les
champs elysées c'était juste avant la
présidentielle il ya le fameux attentat
de la préfecture de police de paris en
octobre 2019 et puis donc récemment à
rambouillet donc voila c'était fanny
stéphanie mon fermé pour les cas les
plus connus et sans évoquer ça c'était
plus qu'il ya des attentes à elle sans
évoquer voilà les policiers qui sont
parfois violemment attaqué comme ça
avait été le cas à viry-châtillon 2016
deux policiers avaient été gravement
brûlés dans leur voiture voilà ce aux
tifosi poteau rebondit sur ce que vous
avez dit donc sur le salaire des
policiers dans le chat de youtube et
d'éclairs les mieux payés de nos pays de
notre pays pardon j'articule sont les
non essentiels et les essentiels comme
les policiers sont sous payés à quand le
monde à l'endroit
je continue de vous lire dans le chatt
n'hésitez pas à poser vos questions j'en
ai relevé une également tout à l'heure
de tim 24
quelles sont les personnes qui nous
demandait quelles sont les personnalités
politiques présentes et allons-nous les
voir alors effectivement alors nos
caméras sur place donc notre reporter
n'a n'a pas pu filmer de politique
présente mais il y en avait beaucoup
beaucoup de journalistes ont relevé on
va dire tous les tous les noms de ces
politiques présents dans cette
manifestation
donc apparemment il y avait donc bien
gérald darmanin il y avait également
beaucoup de parlementaires républicains
de l air donc le patron des sénateurs
bruno retailleau damien abad également
été repérées la vice-présidente de
l'assemblée a ni jo navarre ou encore le
député eric ciotti
donc ça ce sont les journalistes de
l'afp présents sur place qui ont
constaté toutes ces personnalités il ya
également le président ait l'air de la
région auvergne rhône-alpes le rôle
laurent wauquiez qui a été vue tout
comme le candidat à la présidentielle
xavier bertrand jordan bardella
également voilà pour le tour donc là
c'est deux tours à droite il ya
également des personnalités de gauche
qui ont annoncé qu'elles seraient là
ouais ouais on avait quelques-uns il y
avait eu yannick jadot nous d'europe
écologie les verts qui étaient là il me
semble qu'ils avaient aussi olivier à
vérifier mais il semble qu'ils avaient
aussi olivier faure en fait finalement
il ya juste les voilà le mouvement la
france insoumise qui n'a pas qu'il n'a
pas souhaité participer à ce
rassemblement mais sinon tout les voilà
tous les tous les courants tous les
courants étaient présents finalement je
continue de vous lire dans l'autre salle
dans le chat vous êtes nombreux sûr sur
youtube chars stéphane gobelet catherine
leconte qui nous suit depuis le début je
vais faire un tour également sur
lefigaro.fr pour voir si vous avez des
questions pour guillaume points bougez
pas
à kriss kross qui déclare dans le tchat
kriss kross qui est par l'individu enfin
internautes très fidèle à figaro relève
qui ne déclare qu'il a vu laurent
wauquiez aussi également oui ça a été
précisée donc par d'autres journalistes
qui l'ont aperçu le leur où tu es sous
revient et revient sur le verdict on va
dire des attaquants à viry-châtillon des
policiers à la bière à châtillon est-ce
qu'on peut revenir sur ceux sur cette
condamnation qui a été prononcée à
l'encontre de ses agresseurs finalement
c'est un peu à mettre en relief avec ce
qui a été dit dans les discours sur la
réponse pénale sur ce verdict de viry
châtillon
il ya eu plusieurs plusieurs suspects
qui ont été acquittés etc
il y avait eu un brin premier procès là
on appelle les peines ont été moins
lourde donc c'est vraiment un voile
avait un verdict qui a été très mal très
mal accueillie par les par les policiers
je me souviens que l'avocat des
policiers
thibault de montbrial avait même parlé
de naufrage judiciaire donc dans cette
dans cette espèce de cocotte-minute qui
monte depuis des années et qui a fait un
peu déborder le vase où il se ce verdict
de viry châtillon a joué aussi on
rappelle que deux policiers avaient été
gravement brûlé après avoir été attaqué
après avoir été attaqués dans leur
véhicule à viry-châtillon c'est en 2016
si vous nous rejoignez donc nous sommes
toujours en direct pour le rassemblement
des policiers à l'assemblée nationale
les images de la fp viennent de se
couper derrière nous le rassemblement de
toute façon est en train de se terminer
on a vu des manifestants se disperser on
a vu beaucoup beaucoup de monde beaucoup
de parapluies il ya une alternance
de pluie et de beau temps est ce que
l'on est ce qu'on retrouve notre équipe
une dernière fois sur le terrain alors
dès qu'il
il ya le route us ou justement je vous
suis encore sur la page enfin sur le sur
la homepage figaro le roux tués sous qui
rebondit à ce que vous aviez dit sur
viry châtillon en déclarant le problème
n'est pas le verdict de viry-châtillon
mais la réaction en retour donc on
revient encore on refait une boucle
évidemment sur cette réponse pénale
ouais ouais bah c'est vrai que la
réponse pénale c'est un peu le fil rouge
toute la journée quoi il ya eu quand
même des charges dans les discours assez
violente contre contre la justice coller
les policiers se plaignent de peine
voilà qui sont qui sont pas assez lourde
parfois des peines avec sursis il ya
plusieurs exemples qui ont été qui ont
été données mais en tout cas vraiment
oui il faut retenir quelque chose de
cette journée c'est quand même cet
antagonisme qui se dessine et qu'on
connaissait déjà mais là qui a été
vraiment que très clairement exprimée
entre voilà l'antagonisme entre la
police et la justice et l'absence de
réponse pénale en tout cas ressenti par
les parts par les policiers merci merci
nous avoir suivi on va se quitter sur
sur ces mots de guillaume points alors
que la manifestation est en train de se
disperser à nouveau sous la pluie à
paris j'espère que nous avons répondu à
toutes vos questions n'hésitez pas à
revenir sur
notre chatte nous sommes en direct très
régulièrement sur notre page youtube
mais aussi sur la home page du figaro
merci guillaume d'avoir commencé l'année
avec nous à bientôt pour un prochain
sujet et on pourra vous relire donc sur
lefigaro.fr ou dans le figaro pour des
articles faits div justice sécurité a
très vite merci